like i think what it was like when you
were an old like
did radio back then like you always
wanted to up the ante of like how shocky
you could be
so it was like he would take these like
really benign stories in his life but he
would add
really really horrible details to it to
just you know it was like that was the
point right
it was like being as as shocking as
possible like when you did opie and
anthony
all those yeah i remember opie once gave
me like a bull dick
uh-huh like an actual bull dick yeah
okay
and he goes it was raw oh right and i'm
like
oh wow in my mind i'm like that's just
his lung show
i know but when somebody pulls it out of
a plastic like ralph's bag
that's what white people yeah it doesn't
you know imagine somebody just pulling
look at this right yeah this big bulldog
he goes eat it
yeah and i'm like i would never eat it
but i ate it because you know i mean i'm
like
i want to be shocking right why did they
give you the bulldog because you're
asian
i don't know oh whatever like sticking
my tongue in the
the hole of the penis you know what i
mean and i remember
going this is um what am i doing i'm
whoring myself
to be shocking you know yeah what no i'm
just like we mean put your
tongue in the hole like in a [ __ ] is
that big
[Music]
hang on you've never had lung shells
you've never had a woman let me ask you
something right now you think that your
dick is bigger than a bullet
i'm saying my dick is smaller than a boy
i know but have you ever have you had
that woman
stick their tongue inside the hole no no
not all the way inside wait does her
penis hole just
gaping no i'm just not the whole tongue
i'm saying i'm thinking like this like
[ __ ] idiots listen look i'm thinking
you're doing this the bulldog like
no i'm gonna show you something okay hey
there i'm gonna show you something don't
cut your tongue
i'm not gonna cut my tongue look your
father is watching those are his ashes i
know i'm not
oh so careful what kind of all right so
okay it's the bowl penis okay it's
perfect because this is a red bull and
there's a bullet
[Laughter]
right so let's suppose yeah right
obviously
let's say that's a bull [ __ ] wow
yeah all right
obviously i can't stick my tongue all
the way through it right
i'm not houdini that's the way you
describe it i know but but i would you
know
you'd flick oh you you place i say you
place
a little bit of i know i heard but a
little bit of my tongue went through
the hall right that's what i meant got
it i'm not jamming my whole
tongue like i'm whoring myself out
i wouldn't be doing this i'd be in vegas
doing a show
yeah yeah i mean that would be like my
closer yeah watch me you know me
stick my [ __ ] tongue through a bullet
[ __ ]
and the audience would be like apply
right
i would do it it was come out of the
sack part
right sack part and then
and then and then the curtains close and
i get around you know
you know like derek derek delgaudio's
one one-man show yeah oh yeah
that's the opposite
yeah yeah i anyway right forget about
the bulldog i don't even know why
now i don't even know why [ __ ] isn't
even offensive i don't even know if that
is that why did you get did you get
cancelled for it no i didn't get
canceled for it but i just remember
doing things that were like you know
what i mean
not in my character to do things or like
i used to like you know one time you
tell bad stories
here's another they tell untrue stories
embellish exaggerated there's another
thing that i did once yeah that i
it's a behavior that we might have to
cut it out so put this on your thing but
i never talked about this the whole
podcast is edited out it's two minutes
long
i remember when so ike baron holtz
you don't know him but you know ike yeah
and you know
seth meyers right talk show he has a
brother that's very talented
josh myers so ike and ike was on that
josh and i go on that tv with me and
they're
chicago boys right they're second city
and they're just
proper real you know i mean decent
super talented improvisers right
professional
and they get on the show and then we
have to do
promotion so we were promoting on some
radio show we're in a green room
and these proper boys you know they have
shirt tucked in
and they're just ready to do this thing
and there's a bathroom in the green room
i come out of the bathroom
and i have a chest piece you know i mean
i think was the king
jammed in my [ __ ] and i just kind of
walk around
i walk around the dressing room with
this chess piece
in my [ __ ] just to get a laugh from
the guys right
and i remember them since sitting there
you know
like this like sweating and just going
what the [ __ ] is he doing
you know what i mean could they see it
yeah because i turn around
i show him my [ __ ] right bare ass in
my ass yeah yeah i'm completely naked
right and it's a reference yeah yeah so
that so that's in my [ __ ]
obviously the the that that the cross is
in the hole
yeah yeah yeah i'm not gonna i'm not a
[ __ ]
crazy person yeah yeah yeah hey that
crazy person right and i used to do
stuff like that
right just to shock people or you know i
mean
but that's why i think ike's never
didn't invite me to his wedding
because of a chess piece that's the
reason why i don't think that he invited
his wedding because think i think i
think his wife
thinks that i'm weird it's a threat of
nudity yeah or yeah that kind of
behavior i never do that so i
now when i'm around people like you know
when i
was i was on a sitcom a couple years ago
called splitting up together
and one of my producers from mad tv
scott
was a producer on this right and i
walked her to him
at the table read because i hadn't seen
him right i pulled him aside and i go
hey i want to let you know i don't do
that stuff anymore
yeah and he goes i know i know i go i
don't stick stuff on my ball i'm not
that i'm
like professional right i show up on
time right
i know my lines i don't bother nobody
right because before when i was young i
used to do crazy things like
yeah right and what's so funny it's just
the idea of you telling you he's like
dude okay i relax
the president of warner brothers sitting
there everyone's sitting there right
like all these executives
and i'm pulling him aside i don't stick
jeff's pieces he's like i didn't ask
dude
yeah i didn't i know you don't anymore
because you're on a network show
i know but i just remember i just don't
do it
so it's like you know maybe stop
bringing it up and then people just
wait does bob really come up to you and
talk about this chess piece that's why
i've never
this is the first time you ever heard of
this before is the first time i've heard
you do like worse things like
you know farting people's yogurts and
stuff oh yeah go on my perception of you
is completely changed now i thought you
were like this like sweet wholesome like
oh whatever and now you're like oh i
fart on people and stuff that's like a
lot
[Applause]
my percentage of you was very like oh
he's very just like i do my work i go
home
like you're not a party guy like you
just don't write a scandal about you so
but now i'm like there's a ton of
scandal about you that i never
yeah well i mean the krista flanagan
thing
right because it's like um now we're
thinking back it
that is wrong [ __ ] is wrong with you we
need to get chris yeah maybe like
apologize
no i did i apologize oh my god these are
friends yeah we're
great friends and if you're on drugs i
think it's a little bit more forgiving
i mean it's up to her to accept your
apology not me but i'm just saying like
i think if you're on drugs and you
explain it i think she'll be like okay
but i don't obviously you know i've
worked in the last
you know 10 years i've done so many
things
and you know i i'm a professional i
don't
i shake hands i bow i don't care i'll do
whatever
you know you know i mean i'll do the
whole thing yeah yeah and i'll
you know i'm very cordial and
professional
and i don't do nothing bad trish did you
really do taekwondo
i did yeah uh-huh well how far did you
go yeah i went all the way there's like
pictures of me with like my black belt
and stuff like that
i wasn't talking about